2021 comma awards this is the award show
where we award all the community members
who do great work in the community
eric's one of the higher inspectors here
these are real community people that we
know
and uh yeah we're gonna talk about you
know a little bit of open pilot this
year in review all this exciting stuff
it's gonna be fantastic
so uh
let's stop the
copyrighted music before it gets too
late
and uh
yeah let's start by talking about open
pilot this year
all right it's been a crazy year hasn't
it yeah should we flip it to the are
we're gonna oh no we're gonna show it
it's just our notes our secret notes
all right so
we've got open pilot launched november
29th 2016. i guess that's our first
commit yeah it was the first commit uh
that was released in open pilot and that
was 1800 1800 days ago five years ago
open pilot started which is crazy it's
been over five years of open pilot
existing in the world
this year we've had
185 unique contributors including comma
employees that's a lot of no secrets
there are no secrets no secrets oh
should we just show them briefly there's
no secrets everyone has the awards yeah
so their secrets for you know their
secret finale yes right that's right
um
look how many stars we have now dude we
have 31. 7 000 stars and that's up from
21.8 000 at the beginning of the year so
we've had basically a third of the stars
came from this year alone i think in the
top 100 repos at least for
the main language get helpful exercise
so that's pretty cool super exciting
let's climb up
next year
all right now we support over 150 cars
that's actually 157 as of yesterday whoa
[Music]
[Laughter]
someone wants to buy me a s-class we'll
make it work on flex [ __ ] the community
i heard was going to chip in by bmw i3
and give it to us
crap and boxes
boxes
yeah we'll show you the tree it's very
pretty it's the comma the commentary wow
did someone get a common body for
christmas
they sure did george
you've been decorated
for next christmas that's right
today
yeah there's a lot of common body
preorders so
know still get in and you're you'll
still be in the first batch of combat
bodies how many how many viewers you
have to we gotta give people a little
bit of time to get in here and don't
just jump right here well we're not
jumping into the awards you know that's
a good point
sounds good
[Music]
all right well this is good because
we're not in the award time yet
yeah oh here here's here's a fun little
easter egg everybody
uh this is what was this called the
hippo
this uh was a common neo how many people
remember a common neo
yeah
look here it is right next to a new
comma body let me explain the problem
with the hip bone it's small and you
might kick it it reminds me of a lumo
yeah look how tiny it is i don't think
they know what a lumo is i don't think
oh no
google it l-o-o-m-o
we're very festive look at the look at
the ceiling
pretty cool i think the people are in
here i think they're in here too yeah
what about ci runs
how many ci runs
we got 22 kci runs i don't know if that
includes force too you know you can
enable the open pilot ci and your four
with one button no way yeah you go under
settings you enable github actions you
have all
rci coverage we have some stuff that
runs here do their good have actions pay
for it or do ours
i mean ours but you know it's free it's
open source i was so generous for open
source
you know it's gonna scale back you know
it's one of these things we don't talk
about as a world how we're all becoming
so dependent on you know i think it has
gotten way better in this way i agree
but
first
this is the basic startup business model
first you get all the customers then you
lock them in then you jack all the
prices on you know the thing is we'll
just run on those before here i'm really
faster
yeah so total commits 3173
and that's about to commit every three
hours
look who did the most commits this year
oh i wonder who that would be
oh it's this guy named
who who's that
and you did 910 commits all right we
have our everyone clap
we need i mean like a audience a live
audience clapping every time we say
something and we also released 11
releases this year yeah it's almost one
a month yeah so super great all of them
have been pretty big uh we did the zero
e series this year
launched last year kind of late last
year kind of just kept pushing on the
same stuff the lateral toggle will be
removed
uh probably maybe next release release
right after come off the new together
not lateral in general
yeah
well let's go over some highlights with
open pile this year should we ask them
what their highlights are yeah your
favorite features sure go ahead what
were your favorite features of the year
i'll start uh by saying some we shipped
the first
good laneless model this year the first
kl model kl as we branded it back in the
day
and uh yeah that was very exciting
research has been working on you know
making lateral good for years
and finally it was a model that could
drive end-to-end so that was a really
big deal for us
anybody have any favorite things does it
show us all the chats yeah okay
when you view it they have top chat in
live chat oh yeah that's annoying
we shipped forward collision warning
using the model that's pretty much
improved yes
yeah laneless literally used to like not
work
if you drifted at all from the center of
the path they would stop working uh so
we've come a long way
yeah this is amazing how yeah
break never bro never broke for overpass
i don't think yeah i don't know about
that
uh obviously hardware announcements the
comma three launched this year
back it was july 31st
yeah you saw the common body you saw the
red panda you saw the comma three
yeah this is the hardware here yeah we
launched a new platform
and then we launched the evolution of
the eon platform yeah so and the
evolution of the panda platform so
it's a big hardware here hardware team's
been working hard oh yeah and they grew
50 this year
[Laughter]
are the people how about right oh yeah
yeah
it grew one person yeah one person 50
yeah
productions also you know done a lot of
great work this year uh we finished out
all the comma twos pretty much
start building comma threes and you know
still working strong on that sounds
continuously getting better
there's a lengthy mode oh yeah it's
default lane there's yeah there's the
landfill policy and the laneless policy
the socks someone said
socks are good too
all right next year i have to say long
for no dsu toyota
if you want that you got to work on it
yourself we're not interested in weird
cars
though we are hiring a car person so
that'll be on the priority list but you
know like very very low
um
so that's a shot if you want to work on
cars here yeah that's a good point comma
10k finally finished all their images in
2020 we give them new images we did yeah
new images we gave them some official
commentary images it's not even called
tc anymore
common pencil we really appreciate you
you know it's you guys who are making
big model possible
i'm super excited for big model
next year
um but before you have an award let me
know because we'll touch the commercial
back you have some good commercial
man i think it's that time it's
commercial time i think it's commercial
oh come here
this commercial is for
this large rack
it represents 42 use of space
and it's about big enough that i can fit
inside if you said this was an elevator
somebody might believe you it's like one
of those like mine
shaft
this award is brought to you by this
rack and there's gonna be five more just
like it in our brand new compute cluster
uh coming next year thanks to the money
we raised
so that's a commercial for this rack you
can buy one at
cdw or amazon and they come fully
assembled
this just wheeled up to the door
wheeled up the door just like this and
now we have a switch in the rack too but
this commercial is not for the switch
it's for the rack switch
is there is another commercial or is
that the only commercial
all right let me show everyone what the
commies are gonna get
here it is this is
what they're getting those things
oh man they're so nice we really love
them we're going to miss them yeah
they're really nice neon commas that
light up
batteries included
yeah we'll include the batteries
takes
three double a it charges these are
rechargeable
check it out
that would make a good commercial
so you can see we've got some
christmas snacks going oh yeah yeah
we're eating holiday food there's some
donuts under that foil i'm very excited
all right great
cool let's uh announce the first award
it's harold here
harold
let me see what the first award is so
you can announce it i think you'll like
that there's a list i see here's the
first award
oh yeah best tuning
for quadmas
yeah this was the second oh cadmus
all right either way for uh you know
making a pr that
meaningfully improves the tuning
experience
that pr allows people to plot and plot
jugglers kind of all the things that are
relevant for tuning it should really
direct people to
tune more effectively tuning is kind of
this thing where you can just change
things and see how it feels but there
are much more effective ways of
figuring out what are what the right
approach is to improving your car
so kodmus thanks for that it was good pr
hey you also did the the tuning for the
volt oh yeah
yeah for like the four people that have
that car implementing his own uh his own
tuning system
yeah
tama is the best you're right
all right we'll go off to another
commercial break you ready oh yeah
while you're here enjoying your
chips and salsa you know what would be
great to enjoy with chips and salsa if
you had a robot that was just standing
over there balancing and soon
you can
this is the prototype comma body take a
look at it you got to look at it from
top to bottom it actually won't be made
out of wood we're going to replace this
with an aluminum plate but notice how it
has a much
smaller stance than a hoverboard
it has a
a square pipe and the trick to a square
is you can't rotate it so the comma 3
mounted on the common body's head is
always perfectly aligned
with the rest of its body which is not
so true for me you know i'm a little
unaligned but the comma three fits
perfectly on the common body this is a
lot closer to what you're going to be
getting you can actually pre-order one
of these today there's a limited amount
of pre-orders there's only 50 i think
maybe even only 40. uh we sold 25 so far
so you know get an early get a common
body like imagine just yours
if you go on our instagram you can
actually see a clip of it uh one of the
earlier prototypes actually going
outside pre-order your body today yes
you can do it just go to comma dot ai
slash shop and it's in the accessories
page
we didn't set up no we still have a few
all right next up
also harold needs to announce this one
what am i announcing you're announcing
the the most helpful feedback slash bug
reports winner oh yeah so that goes to
hubble sphere
given very constructive feedback
it's got given a lot of negative
feedback with you know attached data
that we can investigate and things that
are reasonable and have all the
descriptions relevant for us to
investigate i've investigated so many
hubble sphere bug reports that have led
to finding real bugs or improving
experiences so that's very helpful if
you guys want to see
how you can be helpful you can look at
all the things that help us through your
posts on discords oh hey hello sphere
or logan i guess uh yeah it's very
helpful it's very informative when
there's all the details attached that
could be relevant to us and have routes
attached and stuff like that
yeah keep it up a good bug report what
makes a good bug report for those who
never made a bug report
they have an issue but they want to
report it how do you do it yeah the most
important thing is that you attach a
route without a route there's very
little we can investigate so that's the
number one thing please how do you
attach a route okay so you can go to uh
connect.com.ai and there you can look at
your drives and there's a button that
says more info or something and there
you can copy the route and the timestamp
in the route to your clipboard so just
post that when you have any complaints
and then uh yeah just kind of give a
good description of your experience um
don't just say like oh it was driving
badly
in a lexus like there's very little we
can do about that if you give a route
and you say what exactly is driving
badly if you say you're on a fork or not
and if you say like this is something
that's changed recently or this changed
since then uh that kind of stuff's all
very useful so
don't tell us
you don't care
hurry i'm on a road trip
on posting gifts that's also super
useful if it's like a driving related
thing if you just attach the gif of
what's going on on the road super useful
remember the difference between being a
hater and criticism is data
i'm going to consider that the ad
we love complaints if you can
investigate them complaints we can't
investigate we can't really do anything
with it yeah so thanks logan you're
gonna get one of these
commies
here it is
one of these for the hackathon oh we did
i don't know
daddy we gave one away what did we give
that away for no
yeah we should also say you know this
this commie will have to come down too
but right now it's being the star of our
christmas tree so that one's going to
take a while
logan didn't get one so he's excited
he didn't get one okay did he did you
get something that last year's stones
yeah you got like the 3d printed color
there's gonna be a real theme here of
same contributors we got we got new
faces in here yeah i know
all right
uh
this one i mean i don't know who should
announce this one i guess i i couldn't i
feel like we should just give it a
dongle id and then it's like a raffle
kind of thing that's what i was going to
do with the word
i think order number's better
okay
next next one uh greg invented for this
year and it's the most common three
training data the most uh data we can
actually use in training a model that
came from a comma 3 this year
and that went to gregory and your order
number is
six seven four two and if that's you
we're shipping to economy
wow
yeah this early early data in the
commentary is very much appreciated in
the beginning there wasn't that much
data
you always have to collect all the comma
three data in every training run because
we want to have similar amounts for the
comma two data yeah so very much
appreciated should we tell them how to
upload yes
effectively let's do that like bring
your device in connect it to wi-fi
ideally upload dm
yeah if you wanna be useful the the most
important things are to mostly be on the
internet most as much as possible so we
just scan for um
routes that have been driven and look
for certain things that we think are
useful and we pull data from those
devices if they're online um having dm
footage is also incredibly useful for
the dm training and future also for the
driving training
and what else is yeah we also we want
dms anyway right later on
yeah all the video without all the logs
without dm are going to kind of use this
at some point right yeah at some point
we'll require all three cameras to train
comma 3 data
some other things that are very useful
um yeah we also filter on forks we it's
not enough
worth the effort for us to make sure
that certain guarantees are met on fork
data so we don't uh use fork data right
now and forks intentionally mess with
the logs which is not fun so yeah
it's kind of adversarial to use for
supports can also have timing issues
yeah we work really hard on the timing
yes you know if you're using a lot of
cpu usage certain messages that should
be logged appropriately uh might might
be too slow uh and then the data is kind
of broken unusable yeah anton dm is
something we're working
on i'm quite impressed with the vm
impression so there's a lot of stuff in
xerox 13 already
okay 013 is gonna be very exciting i was
just uh just about to roll in roll comp
emergent roll compensation which really
helps on like
windy rolled roads just testing that
that seems pretty exciting
cool zero tnt is gonna be great but it's
probably gonna be uh zero eight twelve
barely just came out
and that was
that was a great job
yeah has been amazing so you know keep
driving with your common threes uh
upload all over wi-fi like keep them
connected to wi-fi when you're home
there's so many people who must have
wi-fi where they park and i think that's
great i mean yeah we don't really offer
a cheap way for people to plug the
device inside
yeah maybe we should but they don't need
to in the commentary
with five holes right like a nice five
volt connection a little power find on
the front yeah
all right
so you can bring your commentary inside
plug it into your phone charger or your
macbook it'll work great yeah plugs it
even works with usb-c to usb-c i know
eric
didn't know that but yeah comma two is a
little uh it's a little sketchier but
the comma three is good um i mean this
is another thing we can do i'm down to
like
offer like something really cheap maybe
we can even include the box yeah if we
want people to power devices inside and
helps us yeah
we can we can help with this yeah
i guess most people don't have wi-fi for
their price products you know those
probably do and like like if you had
just have a house
but it's also important to bring it
inside because it will power off at some
point
well i think it'll power off even if
it's inside
we're going to project those things
uh i think we have a check just we have
some kind of checks to see if it's in
the set of things that could be on ours
if it's five volts i think we need to oh
i guess five balls here we could get
five balls we could also do like the
power if the bolts don't go down at all
yeah yeah
but otherwise i don't just count the
power
yeah
yeah seems good um you know
you guys know if prime loses money and
it's about to lose more money
more money yeah
um the cell phone companies are all
switching to paying per gigabyte
unlimited is over the party's over
so we're not going to pass those costs
up to you crimes are ready to rip off uh
i'm sorry it's a reasonable deal
um
so remember that we do lose money on
prime so we're going to really encourage
people to to get on wifi um
until the cell phone company is in two
years pretty much
yes
i remember i remember back in the day i
didn't i had unlimited then i didn't and
i have it again this is a commercial for
bad cell phone companies who took away
unlimited plans
uh don't because now it's per gigabyte
you pay for what you use and it makes
people who use six gigabytes per line
very sad
at least they're going to be fast
gigabytes now it's true it's true yes it
will get faster the prime experience
will improve for the user just the
colossal deep root for us
this will incentivize us to make it good
i guess it really is a plus for you guys
it's going to be great the people's
people keep winning
all right
cool uh i think the next one i mean i
think indeed you should announce the
next one car porter of harry potter of
the year let's get a
a little ramp up to it like oh should we
give it a runner up yeah okay we'll get
a runner up so this is we'll give you a
hint this one is a jason the runner-up
but the winner is also adjacent so i
don't know if there's some correlation
with you know people like jason
uh sunny haven or something like that i
don't know how to pronounce this he's
wrong but he's been the
kind of de facto hyundai maintainer for
a little bit
he did a bunch of carports he's been
upgrading firmware versions
just super helpful um
so shout out to you you're the runner-up
for this year but
our other jason like really killed it
this year uh we should have actually
counted how many individual cards i can
go count after this announcement
yeah
but it's well over 20 i believe oh yeah
57 supported cars congratulations
jason
jay young you win akami
[Music]
car porter of the year and
what's great about
a community member like jason is
they're also willing to help out
thirty-four he said we're nobody oh he's
wrong okay good i'm glad i'm scott i'm
glad to
um
but he
you know oh there we go
now we're
a big improvement
um but he
goes out of the way to help other people
importing cars different brands he helps
gm fresh brand ports he does a great job
he recently fixed an issue that's been
uh
kind of plaguing the gm cars for a long
time where they the ec rule falls um
that's quite strict so
came up with a clever solution there's
only a couple lines
and it's largely mitigated to the issue
yeah so does a lot of great work with
other
sub-communities and helping them make
their cars good too so someone like
jason is just super invaluable
and he's really
not he's not too far behind our real
number one contributor of the year that
we'll shout out a little bit later but
jason is on that's working
after magic first of all
mm-hmm
all right commercial break
all right
have you ever gotten a box in the mail
and had no idea what it is well that
just happened to me greg handed me this
box
so
let's figure out what it is
do you have any better ideas
in here oh scissors scissors would work
too
i'm i'm rich i could use now a box
cutter
this commercial is brought to you by the
latch
how am i going to use scissors to you
got to do this this sounds like it
caught my hand
are scissors allowed on planes
i think so
um
it actually depends where you are when i
was in
the country of georgia they seized my
scissors
[Applause]
all right let's figure out what's in the
box it's package it
oh no way bro
is this a rtx 3080.
i'm gonna play so much minecraft on this
wow it's even better look it has a
blower fan
wow the hot air goes out the back wait
does minecraft use gpu
i'm going to render an ultra high 8k
resolution
gtx
rtx
3080
and also the cuda graph api that runs on
this rtx 3080 but not in the data center
only in a compute cluster
of all those shaders on minecraft it's
gonna be great
[Applause]
good commercial the unboxing
okay
now it's time for shout outs
these are you know they're not getting
commies but we appreciate every
community member
so there's there's a lot to talk about
uh first of all there's shane who runs
the most popular course
hey we did yeah
okay we got one more to announce you're
right we have one more comment
uh you want to hold up akami yeah i feel
like we don't hold up the comment
these are really cool they're custom
made all right china from china
unlike your comments to be built in the
usa that's right
still right
right there
okay
this one goes to the most controversial
community member of the year i'm gonna
let people guess for a second
who's the most
controversial community member of the
year who's winning this commie right now
is stream more more popular than dragon
pilot shane jane's fork uh i just put
dragon most dragonfire devices are
uh oak
no not gucci
well i guess i guess this guy isn't that
controversial we should talk about it
no good who likes good [ __ ]
he's just negative
okay this question is helpful
yes they're very helpful they help
people in the community
if you catch them on a good day they're
gonna you know be amazing fix all your
problems if you catch them on a bad day
they're gonna send a meme in the discord
yes the commie goes to
eric
cloud
shortcut
good job eric
thank you thank you for providing uh
toyota he drives a toyota and he works
at ibm
[Music]
he's sold more toyotas than your average
employee who works at a toyota
dealership
he really has i can't i can't believe it
i met him in person he wears a toyota
hat like this guy's real wait where's
victoria no he just wears a trailer
i don't know where he got the hat
um but yeah eric you did a great job
you helped a lot of people
and uh
you know i think you're you're good at
pointing people to ask the right
questions because sometimes you you know
you come in the discord you don't know
what you're asking you don't look it up
enough and i think that's important he
keeps the discord kind of elevated you
know yeah he does we don't want to hold
people's hands too much keeping the
hacker spirit alive you gotta google
your own [ __ ] that's right
yeah so thank you eric for all you do
cool
okay now the shout outs now to the shout
outs first of all most popular fork
shane
uh shane is the inspiration for our fork
installer so thank you for for that
installer.com.ai lets you install custom
forks and this all came from shane
originally shane interned here for a
while
we appreciate
you what you do in the community yeah i
think his fork kind of delivers um
pretty good experience to a lot of
people who otherwise might not have had
the best experience on stock open pilot
so it's pretty nice you can take stock
open pilot and make some of the little
optimizations everywhere we're starting
to sell like an ad
there's a commercial we're trying to
work
we just want to shout them out properly
all right chain he runs a good fork um a
lot of people run it and they're very
happy with it so
yeah shane a lot of forks are based on
his fork so he's kind of like the king
fork yeah
that's true all right next up
is uh people who got fingerprinting 2.0
working this year
so
we got nissan and mazda
who are these people the nissan people
robin yeah he came to the hackathon
yes martin l wait this is a nissan
oh maybe he helped with it i think he
helped me okay martinella's the subaru
maintainer does a great job merchant
some of his pr's recently
um but yeah i guess he helped on a
nissan
firmware query and rosim io
big shout out to you guys
um you're really improving the carports
yeah big thank you to you guys and we
really need all the cars on fingerprint
2.0 you're working on super one soon
yeah yeah super one's gonna get merged
soon we just got some audio we're to
test it
once we confirm it doesn't interfere
with any other cars um let's go to
merchant great another shout out to mark
now if you want to make your car a tier
one car it needs to support
fingerprinting 2.0
[Music]
gold silver and bronze you got a gold
car
yo
yeah
you'll see about this new thing in the
new year
uh
but um now
ours are whoa
and some cars are doomed to be silver
cars for their entire life
didn't tell the car go out of business
didn't get rid of you
i don't know whose silver car is
[Music]
it's a way of saying if you have a
firmware model if you say honda civic
silver you don't have a firmware
honda civic gold
carpet ram is not metal color
the engaging border depends on your kind
of car yeah you should know
drive a sub to your experience all right
should we go on to matassa okay
i drive the accord every day it's it's
terrible
and yours is terrible too the only
person who has a not terrible accord as
well and this is why it's a slow you
won't even share it with us
yeah it is though that's true it did
inspire some good things
but every day every turn it's like
great
all right and then now we got the mazda
ecu query but really the whole mazda 4
yeah we recently i think this was zero
811 we got the cx-9 merged um it's the
first
supported mazda uh an upstream open
pilot we have some other ones that are
dash cam only because they have a
steering walk out but thanks
yeah he did a great job
um still work in progress i think he's
working on longitudinal now but i drove
it it was pretty decent yeah i think if
it can support longitudinal it can be a
gold car
all right i think there's some space to
get ice
almost gold almost gold
no no it sounds silver yeah
we got the hyundai the toyota and the
bbw
oh wow oh yeah jason like the vw crew
really you're gonna really show up no
wait wait wait really the dws are out
here all exactly the same they're
exactly the same they have a great api
why is that
i don't know
just like i think it was poorly tuned
the wheel was sloppy yeah yeah a lot of
it was turning yeah
yeah i i think jason fixed that like the
actuator delay on it was like
ridiculously way too low so
oh you're telling me it has laggy
steering
no it has like like a toyota level
steering oh i guess it's not that bad
just the sensors yeah yeah okay in open
pilot the toyota was like 0.1 second
delay and for some reason the vw was
like 0.02 or something okay so i think i
think there's just we're not accounting
for the lag in the stack 0.1
sounds good yeah we'll do one more
before the final award yeah um
all right so yeah gold cars coming in
the new year yeah somebody doesn't have
crap torque what is wait vw or can you
cap it
uh maybe they're gonna change it now but
we know it's limited all right tuning
related we've got a somewhat new
contributor here um i think we merged
something with his just today clockness
monster
really looking into the internals of how
the controllers work um
found some things that were
some
very low-hanging fruit he could improve
and uh some
some nice uh prs with you know provided
a goal of verification and he confirmed
it actually works better on his car in
principle it's better so those are the
kind of pr's we're looking for um not
just kind of a pr commitment pilot
so great work clockness monster yes
thank you i think
he was just in chat so thank you very
much he was pretty awkward on this good
work yeah keep it up i think he's gonna
say maybe next year you'll get a comedy
keep keep working at it yeah yeah this
is how we actually hired should we talk
about you yeah this is how we hired each
one go ahead
how do we get igor
so uh igor is now in the hardware team
this is how we grew the hardware team 50
this year
um
and yeah he joined the community
sometime last year
um yeah he got a shout out
i think his first time like
maybe was a week after his first post on
discord he already had like three vrs
merged across different repos he had
like one serial open dvc
pilot
immediately productive and this really
got our attention and he just kind of
kept the ball rolling
and uh we gave him a shout out in the
comments
and i'm not sure we actually got an
award no he just got a shout out but it
inspired him to keep going yeah he kept
going and then he
got a job here yeah so
keep it up if any of you want to work
here i mean one just you know try it out
submit good pr's but uh yeah keep it up
great
uh we also just wanted to shout out a
few
open source repos that we use here
before the metro break i think the
commercial break is it's just gonna be
this is gonna be right after this and
then we do that
yeah okay so first of all a tool used
that we love is plot juggler yes tell me
about the hot chocolate you use it all
the time i do use water a lot of time
but i think it would be
a little more pudding come from a
skeptic
you were a part of a skeptic at first
yeah i was a cloud checker skeptic at
first i had uh i don't know i had a lot
of juror notebooks that did the same
thing
um
so at first when all the jupiter
notebooks i had worked perfectly i
always just used that for a few months
but then i had to start adding things to
them i tried plot juggler instead
and it just worked and now now i'm a
convert yeah he's converted i'm a
convert i think i was skeptical because
my notebooks worked really well and i
didn't think that portugal could be even
less hassle but it was so
fully converted fully converted it's an
amazing tool um so shout out to this
maintainer um davide faconti
i think that's how you pronounce his
name um
and we actually are working on a plugin
to put the video from your device into
the blog so it'll when you scrub and
prop and watch uploader you'll see the
frame at that given time oh wow that
would be pretty cool and you can use
that few cameras your f cameras any of
the camera streams um it'd be really
good
yeah we saw people complaining about
that
it wasn't corporate it wasn't
professional enough
we liked the memes we were thinking
about submitting some new memes upstream
build custom tools we use platforms
all right great and then harold used
this one a lot yeah so
jonathan frey the he's the main
maintainer of acados academics is an mpc
library so we use
through our lateral longitudinal
planning we used to have something else
that was akato and then akados came
along and it was this this nicer cleaner
python version with the same
functionality
which jonathan has been maintaining and
when i started implementing that uh he
started having i mean i'm not that
familiar with npc i was trying to port
rnpc to that and he had a lot of very
useful comments on how to make rmpc work
better and better suited to our
application so his comments were super
helpful since he you know was much more
familiar with all the npc stuff and he
uh helped improve our mpc project so
that was very nice of him and very
helpful should we talk about his project
yeah
john will also be
joining us for an internship in uh
january next month
um since uh since he was so helpful with
all the uh though the academic
supporting and his project is going to
be
probably mostly actuator modeling so
for example in the prius we have this
big problem where the angle sensor of
the steering wheel is not that accurate
so you're not exactly sure where the
steering wheel is
this gives a problem if you're relying
on a pid loop to check where the angle
is then apply torque to get it to the
correct steering wheel angle so if we
can just model how it responds to torque
so that we don't even really need to
rely on the steering angle sensor which
is not that good in the prius we can get
very smooth
smooth lateral control without relying
on their crappy sensor and i think uh
jonathan's gonna do a great job with
that and then those improvements also
carry over to other cars but the prius
is gonna be the main
main benefit benefactor and the prius is
also very popular car so it's very
exciting yeah yeah good prius
you drove the prius the other day how
was it i was so excited i was going to
post in our internal channel i was like
i'm so happy with how prius is driving
and then i hit a turn and
it was just like
i deleted that post
did you post it and then delete it no i
was about to oh i see you know i just
deleted it bye bye css eric said
yes exactly
software's essential
prius it works if you're driving in a
straight line
the longitudinal is great it's so
responsive oh yeah lunchtime
is not that bad yeah it's got a hybrid
motor torque yeah yeah all right you
ready for the final commercial oh yeah
we got a few commercials now
these are
holiday reese's pieces you can see the m
on them it stands for reese's pieces
um
they're red and green and delicious
also
brought to you by
here was the computer
nights without you a midwest emo mix to
end all midwest emo mix
by pets
also brought to you by redis
redis is an open source bsd licensed
in-memory data structure store and then
when you realize it's in memory you
realize you need more memory so our
final commercial is for one point
terabytes of memory how much memory do
you have in your computer i bet it's
less than 1.48 terabytes listen to
nights without you a midwest emo mix to
end all midwest emo mixes today
great
thank you george
all right this is big this is the final
comedy of the night oh this is the one
it's that time
yeah we need to someone pull up the drum
roll on
youtube
people are very shocked by what george
just laid on them
he said that he has 1.48 terabytes of
friends
okay
it's quite long great
[Music]
some calling contributor of the year
i think
he doesn't work at ibm let's take
guesses he doesn't work at ibm
and he doesn't have a toyota hat
he doesn't have a toyota
he has a turtle but he doesn't have a
toyota hat
as far as we know
[Laughter]
okay
[Music]
one two three
[Applause]
dean lee for the second year in a row
you've been
the contributor of the year you've had
by far
the most commits out of anyone
who works
yeah let's do some
he has a chinese toyota ericsson
okay
do you have the what's it the avanza or
something no no it's a corolla
open plot
do you work here dude
[Laughter]
all right and then uh yeah we can just
go in the first position all right let's
check it out
979 closed pr's oh my god so he's almost
at a thousand pr's
that's insane i wonder what his merge
rate is
i bet it's high is it high all
right i mean that's pretty good
all right oh should we start with uh the
contributors page
yeah we can show the full contributors
page so shout out to our 261
contributors
and as you can see dean lee right here
650 nice round number
that's cool you know what's very
important he's twice as good as me this
is the most important thing right here
negative contributions nice he's down 4
000 lines
i'm i'm not good
yeah chris just add lines yeah
whoa no kidding no no no no no no
yeah unfortunately most of us are fake
we deleted ad libraries so oh my god i
added a million lines you just add and
then we're deleting all your stuff
oh that's great but yeah dean lee is now
the third
i mean he's been the third for a while
for a while he's really solidified his
position
he's the
really
wow
wow keep it up dean lee and in a few
years
you might
actually we can do just this year
whereas the internal common place wow
look at that this is just this year also
you can um oh he's not that close alone
that's like 80 comments that is close oh
yeah
that's pretty close click on description
look at the trend though
[Laughter]
let's see he even went through the
chinese new year look at that beautiful
what a year
real shout out to dean lee oh my god 36
commits an open pilot just this month
that's wild and keep in mind he doesn't
get all the quick commits like fix the
typo or anything he's gotta
[Music]
there's no one look how much more he's
committed
to everybody who ever asks me how to
become a great programmer this is how
you do it there's only one way
yeah here every day the dean lee method
he gets his pr support all
he doesn't care he comes back he uh
fixes up what uh we discuss and then
yeah the new one's even better and you
just keep that cycle going
until you get better yeah so we
appreciate contributors like dean lee
uh thank you for contributing to
openpilot
and you've got a comment coming your way
let's find some highlights
your number one fan yes all right
some highlights
oh this is actually a pretty cool one
i don't know how he finds this stuff too
okay what do you do with this one all
right this one's just a cool one to me
but basically
it's very it's small diff but what this
does is
only initially in the boot log so
bootlog is uploaded once when your
device boots up so what this will do is
it'll collect all the logs up until then
from the system logger throw them up
into uh some log and then after that
it'll only collect the logs um from the
point where you went on the road i'm
gonna tell you about off-road so i
filled this pr it would always be all
the ones from when your advice booted up
until you went on-road and that would be
every time you went off-road
know how you found this bug no it's not
really a bug but this is
a little better way to do it that's
great so
it just amazes me how he finds this
stuff yeah he finds all his own problems
on the code base which is pretty amazing
it was amazing
yeah what's another highlight oh we got
another big shout out actually oh we do
so
robert had a great idea last night and
he well i guess europe morning but
um we
had this idea to add the engagement and
disengagement uh kind of hotkeys to
replay so you can click e or d and then
it'll take you the next engage event or
disengage
um and then a couple hours later deemly
already has that implemented there it is
in like a nice generic way so you can
add other features where it's like okay
i want to see all the times where the
alert status changed and you kind of
want to keep jumping between them
he wrote it in like this really nice
generic way where you can just write
that
and he wrote he basically wrote this
whole replay tool which is what
everybody uses now internally and
externally yeah to replay their logs
incredible what an incredible person
or is it
they're sons
quite honestly we don't know lizard
robot the government yeah we're on
[Music]
so we're still unclear is it wally we
should probably get like a wally statue
to commemorate dean lee in the office
look at this 40 pages of pr
i believe is one person
but are they this style is too
consistent yeah this is true
or a class you know a team of people all
trained and deeply
who is that
oh they've
maybe it's a mob programming group oh
yeah i think harold's on to something
yeah that's why do you want to talk
about mod programming you wanna explain
what that is if you guys know about pair
programming
it's all the goodness of pair
programming but instead of two people
you just have a huge amount of people
all sitting around the same computer and
then when you write bugs nobody can be
blamed
[Laughter]
it's amazing you could have 10 people
writing code but no no instead you have
10 people arguing about which code not
to write
and they all have their different
keyboard with the switches they like
it's amazing
would you take a vote one character at a
point this is why george has a big couch
in his office we all pair a program in
there plays open pilots the commenters
think there might be a dean and a lead
oh that's interesting
it could be a sentient ai as well it's
always a possibility
look at this he just finds all his own
issues that's amazing that's pretty
exciting look at all these replay vrs
look how many get close too
it's incredible but then he keeps going
yeah he doesn't discourage him he just
keeps going a lot of my pr's get closed
too
yeah but the thing is you close-up not
somebody else
i think there's a big difference
i'm closing before other people can
it's a good strategy
yeah awesome it's hard to find distinct
projects because it was so consistent
it's like it's it's amazing because you
know nothing he does is pretty much ever
featured in the release notes have we
ever even put his name in the release
yeah we did it for the replay tool
it's just the thing isn't like the stuff
he works on isn't like super user-facing
yeah but you should definitely get more
shout outs maybe in the blog post yeah
and like the back end and like whatever
pilot you know overall gets cleaner and
more stable like a lot of that's thanks
to you yeah yeah for sure
so
in every version there's a lot more
changes than what's in the change lot
i'm sure you know that yeah we sent him
a comma three he was in the first batch
he immediately got it and fixed all
sorts of bugs that's amazing
that's incredible
but yeah
i mean these are all quite small
yeah
like he really knows the code base
outside of this company he probably
knows the code base the best which is
really incredible
yeah thank you
thank
you yeah
clapping sound
oh that's not enough
[Applause]
[Music]
great
well yeah we just want to say thank you
to all the community members uh you know
whether you just make youtube videos you
just have a comma device and you enjoy
it the retweeters the retweeters the
likers the instagram people we even have
instagram people data collectors
thank you to the haters
yeah
it's really incredible you know we're
that we're open source and uh
succeeding making open source software
uh yeah very cool example in the world
that you can actually do this you're
becoming forks
there's like seven thousand forks of
open piles now
i guess muslim
but it might not do much but there's
seven passports and
i think we're getting to a point
where nobody can catch us
you know
there's gonna be a point where the car
manufacturers don't really have a choice
like
could you start open pilot right now and
ever pass us no matter how much
resources you had i'm not sure you could
yeah food for thought
that's true
no
they don't know what kind of box to put
it in
we need to show them the kind of boxes
comma three just put it up there
glue it up there no no the top three has
to be a small metal box without a screen
then the car manufacturer is trusting
it's incredibly reliable
great thank you everybody that was
another year in the books
and uh we'll see you next year for the
kami's uh 2020 to
trustworthy
we should get like a metal pink
yeah it might help
thank you all for watching
happy holidays
merry christmas happy new year bye
everyone